today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
welcome everybody we are we're getting
close very very close to the election
and um we predicted this timing could
happen
you don't have to be a master of
statistics or mathematics
to look at the coronavirus numbers and
understand that
we could be easily heading towards a
hundred thousand cases a day
within several weeks and when dr fauci
said it months ago when fauci said if we
don't do x y and z
we could be looking at 100 000 american
coronavirus cases per day in the fall
some people said he sounded crazy some
people said it made no sense some people
said oh
lockdown fouch you wants everything
closed forever
but indeed when you look at the numbers
it appears that we are going in a
direction
where uh part of the country is
pretending as though the pandemic is
over they're behaving as though it's
over
but we are set seeing new
record numbers going back several months
in terms of cases
of course you have people saying well
cases are up but deaths aren't up
um and that is true sort of so far
although if you look at the seven day
average we now
are seeing an uptick in the number of
deaths so let's sort of look at
everything from the beginning
reset the pandemic so we can all get on
the same page what i am going to put on
the screen for you here
and i will describe it if you're just
listening is a chart of us
cases per day dating all the way back to
february and then
the blue line that you see that's the
seven day moving average which shows us
the general week to week direction of
cases are they generally going up or
down
so you'll see that in mid april we
peaked with about 32 000 cases a day
health measures were able to reduce that
down to about 20 000 cases a day
in late may but then things started
opening up
and dr fauci said you know we're not
really at the place where we can do this
we're only down to 20 000 cases a day we
need to be down at least to 10 000 a day
with at least a million tests a day to
reopen
people didn't listen so we got another
spike and we went back up not to 32
000 cases a day but all the way up to 70
000 cases a day in mid july
and then again with people being mostly
outdoors and lots of places taking more
serious measures
we were able to get back down to 35 000
cases a day
in early september so the first time
after a spike we got down to 20k the
next bike
was bigger and we only got down to 35k
and then we reopened more stuff movie
theaters casinos
and now in the last few days we've had
some of the
worst days including 72 000 cases in one
day
on friday and when you look at the trend
line now
you see that we are headed up and
potentially to
100 000 cases in a single day within a
few weeks
now there are folks who are going to say
but but but but david deaths aren't
going up
deaths lag cases by at least two to
three weeks
we now are better at treating this and
better at keeping people alive longer
so it would extend that lag time
even a little bit more but if you look
at the trend line on deaths
you will see that after a seven week
decline in the death trend line
it leveled out in early september and in
the last few days there's a small but it
is there
blip upwards on deaths and the
expectation is that
it will continue to climb now i am the
first to admit
that there is some good news here which
is that we are better at treating this
now than we were six months ago
i expect that given x number of cases
today
versus x number of cases six months ago
fewer people would die today now in part
that's because younger people on average
are getting the disease right now
in part it's because you have very few
if any hospitals overwhelmed
right now and in part it's because we
have better treatment protocol and some
medications that are
helping some of the sickest patients as
soon as hospitals get overwhelmed if it
happens which they might as we enter flu
season
that could change and you could see the
rate of death go
up as well hopefully it won't now
similar things are happening in other
countries you remember
italy was one of the early hot spots
brutally hit
they got it under control they have now
had their worst week in the entire
pandemic in terms of cases in the last
week they had a record
almost 12 000 cases yesterday so
italy is spiking one other example
france which had it very much under
control
also with record spikes over the last 10
days
much worse than what they had in march
and april and remember
italy and europe in general have not yet
had a second spike if you look
at our numbers we had the april spike
and the july spike and now
we're seeing spike number three italy
france
european countries avoided that second
spike all summer
we may be heading to something
unconscionably worse
than what europe is heading towards and
meanwhile
donald trump continues to hold huge
rallies so we'll talk
on the bonus show later this week about
what fall and winter might look like
individually i've been reading some
medical recommendations about
thanksgiving and and sort of dealing
with some realities there
let me know what you are planning for
whether you're in the united states or
not
um for the next four months essentially
and we'll discuss that on an upcoming
bonus show
dr anthony fauci was interviewed on 60
minutes last night he's the top
infectious disease doctor in the country
one of the top
and most trusted public health officials
in the country
and it's it's both interesting and
really depressing and tough to watch i
want to go through a few of the things
that dr fauci said it was a wide-ranging
interview
this was an interesting moment dr fauci
was asked
whether he was surprised that donald
trump personally got coronavirus listen
to what dr
fauci said were you surprised that
president trump got sick
absolutely not i was worried that he was
going to get sick when i saw him
in a completely precarious situation
of crowded no separation
between people and almost nobody wearing
a mask
when i saw that on tv i said
oh my goodness nothing good can come out
of that
that's got to be a problem and then sure
enough it turned out to be a super
spreader event
so fauci not only not surprised that
donald trump got coronavirus but clearly
and unequivocally pointing out
the white house event for the nomination
of amy coney barrett
that was a super spreader event we know
just of people
affiliated with trump never mind randos
in the audience
chris christie kellyanne conway the
president of notre dame
trump others caught covid probably at
that event and dr fauci he seems to just
be sick of it at this point and you'll
see why in a moment
just telling it like it is in this next
clip and this is part of what fauci is
sick of
you will see dr fauci going for a walk
now with armed security
once an avid runner at 79 dr fauci now
power walks
flanked by federal agents what's that
all about
that's sad the very fact that a public
health
message to save lives
triggers such venom and animosity to me
that it results in real incredible
threats to my life and my
safety but it bothers me less than the
hassling of my wife and my children
they've been threatened
yeah i mean like give me a break have
there been death threats against you and
your family
well all of you you're not just me but
harassment against the rest of the
family what is wrong with this country
we have a country where i'm not going to
say half but
20 25 30 of the country
is arguably institutionalizable if
that's a word and it's not but you
understand what it means
uh in their disconnect from reality and
they're backwards i mean it's directly
it's it's to call it anti-social
behavior
it understates what it actually is
threats to dr
fauci and his wife and his daughters are
their leading public health officials
in any other country put in this degree
of danger where they need
full-time armed security we are
backwards here it's shameful
it's embarrassing the the english
language almost
lacks in its ability to characterize
this for what it is
and um what when you look at what's
going on in other countries
you're starting to see leaders of
both public health and political leaders
in other countries not even tolerate the
nonsense we have interesting clips over
the last couple of weeks from
ireland from new zealand australia and
other places
in this country the president is
actually
fomenting this type of stuff against dr
fauci
very interestingly one of the big
conspiracies or
pejoratives applied to dr fauci and joe
biden is they want to lock down
everything forever
they're they're just about lockdowns
kill the economy lock it all down
even dr fauci himself says
he would be very hesitant to recommend
a national lockdown and this is
important
because trump and the right have been
caricaturing him
as wanting lockdowns forever all the
time fauci says quite simply here
it's a last resort it's not what i want
how bad would things have to get for you
to advocate a national lockdown they'd
have to get really really bad
first of all the country is fatigued
with restrictions so we want to use
public health
measures not to get in the way
of opening the economy but to being a
safe gateway to opening the economy so
instead of
having an opposition open up the economy
get jobs back or shut down no
put shutdown away and say we're going to
use public health measures
to help us safely get to where we want
to go
and of course this is the problem half
the country is so busy saying
we won't lock down which fauci isn't
suggesting
that they're ignoring the reality of the
pandemic they're ignoring the things
they can be doing to prevent spread
including not having big parties and
events particularly indoors
masks lots of other measures but the
point is this is not a guy
itching to lock down the country and why
would anyone be itching to lock down the
country it's ridiculous
really important question that came up
uh
has the white house been controlling
when and where dr fauci can speak to the
media there have been rumors that dr
fauci
has not been allowed to do certain shows
and fauci says yeah they have been
limiting me take a look
during this pandemic has the white house
been controlling when you can speak
with the media you know i think you'd
have to be honest to say yes
uh i certainly have not been
allowed to go on many many many shows
that have
asked for me one of the most trusted
voices in america and yet
you're not there you're not allowed to
talk with us so can you understand the
frustration that maybe there's been a
restriction
on the flow of information on
transparency you know i think there has
been a restriction john but
but it doesn't it isn't consistent
the most trusted public official on the
topic of coronavirus according to
polling
every poll fouchy the most trusted on
the issue of coronavirus
blocked from speaking to people blocked
from appearing on shows
it's a sick country and in fact
trump rep you might remember this trump
replaced
fauci at his public events with this
doctor named scott atlas who's a
neuroradiologist now understand
neuroradiology is a specialty of
radiology what is a radiologist a
radiologist is a doctor
who sits in a room and i'm not demeaning
what radiologists do i'm just telling
you
they don't know about pandemics and
infectious disease a
much like you wouldn't go to a
podiatrist to deal with coronavirus you
wouldn't go to a neuroradiologist
radiologists look at x-rays mris ct
scans and other imaging to diagnose
conditions
when i went in for my appendectomy they
did a ct scan
it was sent to a radiologist who looked
at the scan and said
appendicitis i'll take 600 thank you
very much
that is what they do neuroradiology is a
subspecialty someone who looks at brain
spine and neck images why is that person
the most prominent medical figure around
donald trump
for dealing with a pandemic because he
says what trump wants him to say
masks don't really work he deleted that
tweet
let's look at herd immunity let's open
everything
nearly a hundred stanford immunologists
uh signed a letter
calling out this guy and this is who
trump promotes
as dr fauci is blocked from being on
shows
and needs armed security to go for a
walk with his wife
there has to be some reckoning for this
doesn't there does the i get i mean
i guess the reckoning is tons of people
are getting sick and dying relative to
other countries but
the the consequences should affect the
people who ran the policy
not innocent people who through this
failed policy
are catching the virus and dying it's
it's absolutely disgusting and it only
reinforces and highlights underlines the
urgency of removing joe biden
i'm sorry removing donald trump and
removing these doctors and putting in
joe biden i voted this weekend
uh you can find video of me voting all
perfectly beautiful legal video uh on my
instagram
david.pakman let me know if you voted
either there or you can find me on
twitter pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for if
there's a full book you're thinking
about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so as we get closer and closer to
election day there are
not surprisingly some numbers that are
not giving me a high level of confidence
that i know
some in my audience already have about
the
seemingly inevitable pending victory of
joseph r biden jr now
i already told you last week that as of
about
22 days out in three key states michigan
wisconsin and pennsylvania hillary
clinton had a bigger lead in 2016
than joe biden had last week we will
update
update those numbers this week but it
was a cause for maybe not concerned but
at least for being
very very cautious there is another
signal that
given the realities of the election is
not a great signal for joe biden and
this is both voter registrations in some
states
and mail-in ballot requests and even
early voting numbers in some
states and remember why why are we
analyzing it in this way
because this is an electoral college
election
the first candidate to get to 200 the
only candidate to get to 270 electoral
votes
wins overall new voter registrations
and early voting and mail-in ballots
don't matter
it matters in states that would make a
difference if democrats have registered
way more new voters in california great
but joe biden's going to win california
it's not going to move the needle and
get joe biden anymore
electoral votes likewise if we assume
that early voting will be skewed towards
biden
but republicans ask for more mail-in
ballots that would be a red flag and in
the states that could be
key there are some numbers that look
good for trump so
let me give you a couple of examples
despite
michigan polling having joe biden seven
points ahead
in terms of mail-in ballots requested in
michigan
republicans have requested more mail-in
ballots than democrats
in michigan so remember we were
expecting mail-in ballots to be
overwhelmingly biden voters
biden is plus seven in michigan polling
and yet 41 to 39 republicans have
requested
more mail-in ballots and in total if you
combine mail-in ballot requests plus
early votes
republicans have voted more than
democrats in michigan
that's not a number that i look at and
say great
joe biden's got michigan in the bag
similarly if we look at the state of
wisconsin which is a very
important state ended up being
extraordinarily important in 2016.
despite joe biden leading the polls by
six
in wisconsin republicans in wisconsin
have requested more mail-in ballots by
40-38 it's a small margin
if you include mail-in plus early voting
republicans are down only 38-40 and
again
biden supposedly is winning by six there
we expect biden would win the mail-in
vote
but that trump would win the in-person
vote on november 3rd
what we are seeing so far does not
correspond
with the expectations based on polling
and preferences about voting
by mail versus voting in person these
are not good numbers now
in some other states things look fine
pennsylvania for example which is
looking like it's going to be a key
state
the numbers in pennsylvania are very
skewed in favor of democrats democrats
requesting way more mail-in ballots
democrats voting early by a huge
majority in pennsylvania it's like 65 to
25
major margin doesn't mean it's over but
the point is
pennsylvania is looking much better
based on what we expected
relative to wisconsin and michigan the
point here is
we're what 15 days out there is no
sense in taking any chances given the
numbers that we are seeing so far
you can find a way to make the numbers
look just great for joe biden just leave
it alone
biden is winning today in the popular
vote
by more than hillary was on election day
2016 but that's not the way that this
election will be decided when you
compare
15 days out to 15 days out the numbers
change when you look at registrations
which i want to do the numbers don't
look quite so good let's briefly talk
about that
republicans have registered more voters
than democrats
since the primary elections this year in
the states of
florida north carolina and pennsylvania
that's not good it's very difficult to
extrapolate that one number
to the results we would get on november
3rd but it is
cause for if not concern it is cause for
very
much caution i voted on saturday
i published a video of me voting uh to
my instagram
i used a real ballot dropbox i think i
got about 150
messages from people saying david that
doesn't look like a postal service
mailbox
it's because it's not i used an official
city of boston registered clearly
delineated
well-known dropbox at a state building
it's a real dropbox i didn't mail my
ballot i dropped it off i haven't been
tricked it's okay
let's all do it let me know of course
about any irregularities that you
experience or
any trouble whatsoever that you run into
so this october surprise
published in the new york post last week
about joe biden's son hunter biden
is i'm calling it on the verge of
although some people say it already has
spectacularly backfired on the trump
campaign
the entire story published last week was
supposed
to make joe biden look really really bad
it was supposed to prove that joe biden
is corrupt
and a bad person and that so is his son
hunter biden corrupt terrible bad person
and a drug addict not only has the story
failed to hurt joe biden so far some of
what is coming out
as being joe biden's alleged text
messages to his son
are actually just making him look like a
good kind loving dad an empathetic
person
and republicans have no idea what to do
now before we even get into the
specifics
um i i want to let you know
that we've since found out that the
writer of this story
the primary writer of the new york post
story bruce golding
didn't even want his byline on the
article
because he knew it lacked credibility
many new york post staffers we've since
found out thanks to a great piece in the
new york times
new york post staffers were saying we
shouldn't even be publishing this story
we don't even trust the reliability of
the sources we question the timing
and we now know rudy giuliani was a big
factor in pushing for the story's
publication so
number one even internally many at the
new york post
knew the story wouldn't shouldn't be
published but it was published okay
first of all the underlying premise of
all of this is that joe biden did things
as vice president because hunter biden
was on the board
of a ukrainian energy company including
getting a prosecutor
fired that main story about
joe biden getting a prosecutor fired as
as a gift to hunter biden
has long been debunked even if you
accept
everything else in the new york post
story is true
it does nothing to change that the biden
prosecutor firing story
is a lie joe biden was involved
in the ukrainian situation with the
prosecutor at barack obama's direction
a coalition of countries was involved in
that the idea that biden went
and did it for hunter biden because of
his consulting contract
widely debunked already okay then some
texts are published as part of this
story
texts purported to be between joe biden
and hunter biden
what we learned from those texts are or
is that joe biden is a caring dad
and talks to his son in a way that i've
never even heard of donald trump
speaking to his children he seems to
love and
and support his son hunter biden it's
clear joe biden
loves his kids generally speaking it's
not super clear that trump does at least
not in the way
that resembles healthy parenting that
helps joe biden it makes joe biden look
better and in the text you also
see again if the texts are real joe
biden say give me a call
because i am sure that my text messages
are a target
and indeed joe biden was right about
that now thirdly
nbc news is reporting that federal
investigators
are looking at whether the emails
allegedly describing activities by joe
biden
and hunter biden supposedly found on a
laptop supposedly at a delaware repair
shop
those emails are potentially linked to a
foreign intelligence operation
i i it's like it's happening again
burisma
apparently was hacked by the same
russian intelligence unit that was
involved
in the hacking of the democratic
national committee in 2016. it's
happening again
that is now being investigated the
washington post also reported overnight
that u.s intelligence agencies warned
the white house last year
that trump's lawyer rudy giuliani was
the target
of an influence operation by russian
intelligence
rudy giuliani has since admitted that
it's possible i believe he said it's a
50 50 shot
it's possible that he was working with a
russian spy on this story
don't need to make any conspiracy just
look at what rudy himself himself said
so far it does not seem that this
october surprise
has hurt joe biden at all it may end up
damaging republicans it may end up
damaging donald trump's campaign more
than anything else
for a second consider how absurd this
all is
the trump campaign is trying to smear
joe biden by releasing
the loving emails and texts that he sent
to his son
guys rumor has it joe biden cried when
his first wife and kid died what a loser
that's the level of stuff that they are
resorting to and trying to pull off here
and really i know that when trump does
his rallies and talks about hunter the
crowd boos and cheers and jeers and
whatever
it doesn't seem to be a people don't
seem to be falling for
it and what underlies this all to some
degree
think about it is that republicans
consider
empathy and kindness and sensitivity to
be weaknesses
trump certainly sees it that way for
sure this is why it doesn't make sense
to argue with them they can't behave
like normal humans
it could be a result of anger fear
authoritarianism depending on which
group you were talking about
but you can't reason with them and as i
read through the alleged texts
between joe biden and hunter biden i
like biden more
the only really groundbreaking thing
here that came from this
supposed october surprise is that rudy
giuliani
is now being investigated for
potentially working with russian spies
maybe doesn't come as a huge shock to us
but so far i know that there are some
saying there's much more coming
and it's going to be much worse well
we've got 15 days to go
okay so they'd better get it out soon
what is out so far
does not strike me as even remotely
damaging to joe biden within a few days
we will have post new york post story
polling
and we'll be able to see for ourselves
we'll have more on this
on our instagram at david pakman show
and if you want to see me voting this
weekend
powerfully voting uh follow me on
instagram
david.pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
despite the horrifying coronavirus
numbers i uh told you about earlier in
the show donald trump is now holding
daily rallies or even multiple rallies
each day
at least one of these rallies has now
been specifically tied to more than 20
cases of coronavirus
but that's a different story the real
story here for us today
is that at his latest rallies donald
trump has become
even more authoritarian than we've seen
him be uh
be before including vowing to lock up
the bidens which we will also discuss in
a moment but these
rallies are a true dystopian nightmare
including trump having the entire crowd
boo and jeer at the media the exact
opposite of a president who respects a
free press
but there's also a desperate and almost
practical
realistic element of trump at these
rallies trump seems to be recognizing
that he indeed might lose to joe biden
in just a little over two weeks
and trump also seems to recognize or at
least admit
that it would be very embarrassing for
him to lose because as he says
biden is the worst candidate in history
that that's not
true but the real reason it would be
embarrassing for trump to lose is with
all the bluster with all the the
narcissism and
and the attacks on the left and on joe
biden
there would be an irony in trump losing
to a guy
he claims is a terrible opponent but
there's one thing that donald trump has
now said
in some form um in terms of
one state like for example trump has
previously said in the last couple of
weeks
he goes to north carolina and says north
carolina if you don't vote for me i'm
never coming back to north carolina iowa
if you don't vote for me i'm never
coming back to iowa
but now trump has taken it up a notch
which is actually quite interesting
trump says if he loses to joe biden
he might leave the country check out
this clip from his make and georgia
rally a few days ago
i shouldn't drop because you know what
running against the worst candidate
in the history of presidential politics
puts pressure on me
could you imagine if i lose my whole
life what am i going to do
i'm going to say i lost to the worst
candidate in the history of politics
i'm not going to feel so good maybe i'll
have to leave the country i don't know
so this is fascinating for a few reasons
first it's clear trump's primary
feeling will be embarrassment if he
loses that's predictable thanks to
trump's ego
and his narcissism now there are some of
you who will say
narcissists like trump can't feel shame
he will just say that it was rigged yes
of course he will say it
but there is no doubt that privately at
least
it will be hugely embarrassing to trump
if he loses to joe biden
which i would love to see second there's
the idea of
hiding if he loses and this is becoming
more and more commonly mentioned
indirectly i've said before in the
immediate aftermath
if donald trump does lose he may well
deny he lost
claim it was rigged be on twitter 24 7
be doing
you know press briefings all the time
accusing this that and the other person
of cheating him out of whatever
but if it is eventually undeniable
that trump lost if joe biden is going to
be the next president of the united
states i wouldn't be shocked to see
trump all but disappear
just sort of evaporate into the ether
and the idea of never going to states
he loses again and now of leaving the
country is another indicator
not literally i don't believe trump will
literally leave the country
but the underlying emotion of the idea
is there that trump will just kind of
disappear and you won't hear from him
again
the reality is i think the idea
of a trump-free united states would be
so welcomed by tens of millions at
minimum
that the only way trump would really
consider leaving the united states
leads us directly into layer three of
this conversation which is the idea
of donald trump evading prosecution
after being president now by the way is
trump says he's patriotic and his party
is patriotic
is there anything patriotic about saying
you will abandon your country if you're
democratically removed but again
i don't think it is literal but think
about
what leaders leave their countries after
their reigns of terror are over
it's authoritarian dictators fleeing
arrest
fleeing consequences this is something
we've come to see
many times globally when authoritarians
lose their grip on power
they go to a country without extradition
to live
out the rest of their lives and if i
must tell you
there are plenty of countries that would
no doubt love
to make use of a former american
president who will just trash talk the
united states
and trump would easily find safe haven
if in plenty of places if that's what he
wanted to do
he would become he would be welcomed to
become
a sort of uh weaponized agent of social
discord
much like his presidency has been i know
many of you are obviously thinking about
russia
this is bigger than russia okay now the
realization that i came to as i was
watching this farce take place in macon
georgia was
if we don't want all of this exact same
stuff to happen again in four years
we have to make sure that this guy is
removed now all of these questions about
trump leaving coming
all this different stuff we've got to
remove them now
uh talk about making america great again
by the way trump leaving and ideally
taking those kids of his with him
that would be one of the most powerful
steps donald trump could take
to improve this country and if you're
not yet convinced of that
let's look at some more clips from a
recent rally that donald trump did
so now that we've discussed the idea
trump floated of leaving the country if
he loses to joe biden
let's get to the really authoritarian
stuff from trump's last few rallies now
i know i know
what's more authoritarian than trump
threatening to do what many dictators
have done which is
flee their country when they lose their
grip on power but trump did something
even more dystopian at some recent
rallies
over the weekend uh he again
insisted that he would lock up
the bidens remember that donald trump
vowed to lock up hillary clinton back in
2016.
lately trump has been saying obama and
biden committed the greatest political
crime in the history of the united
states
against me and yet he hasn't been able
to actually name a single law that was
broken
but it's now taken on an even uglier
tone trump
is straight up saying the bidens should
be jailed take a look
i'm telling you that biden family and
others but that biden family is corrupt
it's a corrupt family
and with me and my kids let me tell you
my kids
i'll tell you something though i
understand you lock them up you should
lock them up
lock up the buttons lock up hillary
guacamole this is outrageous
authoritarianism this is a nightmare
and it has become normalized many of us
don't even react anymore
trump basking during this event
in big cnn sucks chance
uh you see many people not even wearing
masks and trump directing
the crowd's anger against the media in
the back as trump often points to
10 million dad please i had a great
father
i'm not just running against biden in
that corrupt family i'm running against
the left wing corrupt media
and we're running against big tech
[Applause]
the authoritarianism continued all
weekend trump doing these now daily
sometimes two
even three of these in a day continued
the next day in michigan at a similar
rally
before we continue with the
authoritarianism a brief interlude
trump still struggling to speak here
very powerfully struggling with the name
christopher columbus take a look
if you're italian do you happen to like
christopher or columbus
christopher okay so back to the
authoritarianism trump says lock them
all up
as his sycophants chant lock her up
about michigan governor gretchen whitmer
remember she was recently the victim
of a foiled or the the potential victim
she was the target and potential victim
of a kidnapping plot hatched up by some
q anon
trumpists and they want to lock them all
up i mean what you're doing in michigan
has been
amazing now you got to get your governor
to open up your state
okay
and get your schools open get your
schools open
the schools have to be open right
lock them all up lock them
all up that's an idea that doesn't seem
to account for due process
does it and this just continues the
crowd wants everybody locked up it's a
mob
of people demanding the imprisonment of
individuals
not charged with and in some cases
not even wildly suspected of any crimes
for the second time in a single speech
trump fans chanting
lock her up about gretchen whitmer
that's right she's doing it for
everybody is locked down except my
husband he could go sailing anytime
[Applause]
a guy like biden and the democrats want
to keep michigan locked up
locked down and closed for business no
it's so badly hurting you stay
it is reminiscent of mussolini just
mango colored that's the difference it's
tangerine colored
that's the difference between mussolini
and the stuff that we are seeing right
here
uh and and trump uh uh of course
responding
to chance of lock her up by saying are
we having a good time this was about
hillary clinton
you know they want to erase the name of
clinton yeah hey that'll be next
crooked hillary will take her name does
she ever name it
i don't know if she's got her name on
anything right
if she does i'm all for it take it down
[Applause]
crooked
are we having a good time so um
yeah that's very very ugly and
aggressive stuff that is just normal at
these trump rallies
trump then again with this stuff about
maybe we'll be here four more years
maybe we go an extra four and i'm gonna
make a point here that is more about
trump's fans than what trump says
himself
we'll be here for four years and then if
we decide to go for an extra four or
eight or something
[Applause]
[Applause]
well i think 12 is going to be now the
gold standard that'll be
that'll be hey that'll be the new chat
so people like to argue
like when trump talks about eight more
years 12 more years
is trump kidding is he just trying to
trigger the left
that's not the primary issue to me trump
is just one guy
the real issue to me is that the crowd
cheers for it trump joking about
trying to seize power beyond what is
constitutionally allowed
and to be you know get a third term a
fourth term whatever
okay it's wacky maybe it's a joke maybe
it's not
the fact that the crowd cheers is the
nightmare
uh if you like this stuff you are
unauthoritarian whether trump means it
seriously
or not and that's where i believe our
focus on this should remain
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so for some reason the trump campaign
continues to think that it's a good idea
to send people like eric trump and his
wife lara trump out to do interviews
despite being completely unprepared
and unqualified to be doing them in
favor of
donald trump's reelection campaign last
week we had this interview that eric
trump did with abc's jonathan carl
it went horribly wrong and then this
weekend we had an interview on cnn with
jake tapper interviewing eric trump's
wife
lara trump and if you're even at all
human
you almost start to feel bad for her you
know some of us do have this empathy
response
because of how horribly wrong this went
we did learn
over the last four years tens of
millions of americans have no
empathy response some of us still do
let's look at some clips of this
jake tapper mentions the town hall
questioning related to when did trump
last
test negative for coronavirus is it
possible trump knew
at the first debate with joe biden that
he had the virus
and um lara trump just falls apart
president trump gave four different
answers in about 60 seconds
four different answers on whether or not
he had tested for coronavirus before the
first debate you were at the first
debate
yes or no did president trump test
negative
within 72 hours of that first debate as
was required by the debate rules
i assume the answer is yes i was not
physically there with him and i worked
for the
campaign not in the white house i don't
i i'm giving you my honest answer i do
not know but i assume the answer
is that he tested negatives but you
don't know for i don't see why
you don't know for a fact why would the
president knowingly test positive
and go to a debate i didn't say he did
i'm just trying to we've been trying to
get a straight answer for weeks as to
when
he last tested negative and we haven't
gotten an answer the negative i'm sure
it is
okay but you don't know so here's the
question you're not giving a direct
answer
you you don't know i'll take you at your
word so of course at this point the most
likely scenario
is that trump either simply had no tests
before the debate
remember they said on the honor system
oh we're too late for the debate to test
us but
we tested negative they either didn't
really test trump
or they tested and he came up positive
and they covered it up
so that trump could participate and lara
trump asks
why would trump do that like why would
trump deceive anybody
the reasons range from relatively benign
like trump just really wanted to go to
the debate
to the sinister like trump wanted to try
to infect joe biden i'm not alleging
either side but i'm telling you there's
a very broad range of why
trump would cover up or not be tested
for coronavirus the answers are all bad
none of them is good
uh this continues with lara trump lara
trump
then uh asked about
the chance of lock her up
that are frequent at donald trump's
rallies when trump
attacks gretchen whitmer gretchen
whitmer the democratic governor of
michigan
against whom a plot was uncovered to
kidnap and possibly assassinate her and
trump
has actually been ginning up more ire
against gretchen whitmer here is lara
trump with complete and total
what about ism like sometimes people
threaten me too hector tweeted last
night
i am the governor's deputy digital
director i see everything that is said
about
and to her online every single time the
president does this at a rally
the violent rhetoric towards her
immediately escalates on social media
it has to stop it just has to don't you
think that
the president should tone it down when
talking about people about whom there
have been literally
threats against their lives in this very
very
heightened time well gosh i would like
to show people my
social media and the threats against me
the threats against my children
uh when you have members of uh you know
the democrat party
uh coming out and telling people get in
their face go
harass them i mean this is not just on
one
joe biden so joe biden isn't saying
things like look
anything against you or your family or
your children is horrible
detestable and i condemn it right now
and if there were any democratic
politicians
that were you know throwing fuel on the
fire i would say
tone it down why aren't you toning it
down but
i i don't look at threats based on what
party
are the recipients and my question is
shouldn't everybody just
tone it down including your dad your
father-in-law
well look this is he wasn't doing
anything i i don't think to provoke
people to
threaten this woman at all he was having
fun at a trump rally and quite frankly
there are bigger issues than this he was
just having fun
at a trump rally encouraging
more disdain which we know led to ire
and threats of violence and a plot to
kidnap a democratic public official
don't you get it guys
trump was having fun and that's what
matters when i watched this the first
time preparing it for you guys i
i was reminded of something my mom used
to say growing up
whenever i i would bug my little brother
and just have fun at his expense um and
i would say oh it's just fun
it's just funny my mom would say and i
remember it like it was yesterday well
it's because she said it a week ago when
i was bugging him but
she said if both people aren't having
fun
it's not valid fun and i think that
that would absolutely apply here then
um lara trump was asked to explain why
she appeared to publicly mock biden for
his
stuttering problem that he has had for a
very long time
and lara trump says no that wasn't
mocking him for stuttering it was
mocking him for cognitive decline i had
no idea that joe biden had a stutter
joe biden as we all know his work to
overcome a stutter
and one of the speakers at the
democratic convention was a young boy
who the vice president inspired named
braden harrington
uh take a listen it was really amazing
to hear that someone like me
became about
[Laughter]
president braden harrington a very brave
young boy
you made this comment earlier in the
campaign about joe biden
let's take a listen to that
every time he comes on stage or they
turn to him i'm like joe can you get it
out let's get the words out joe you kind
of feel bad for him
how do you think it makes little kids
with stutters feel when they see
you make a comment like that
uh first and foremost i had no idea
that joe biden ever suffered from a
stutter i think what we see on stage
with joe biden jake
is very clearly a cognitive decline
that's what i'm referring to it makes me
uncomfortable you have
you are no this is so amazing it's so
amazing to me that and
try and figure out an answer a cognitive
decline you're trying to tell me that
what i was suggesting
was i think that you were mocking his
stutter yeah i think you were mocking
his stutter and i think you have
absolutely no standing to diagnose
somebody's cognitive decline
i would think that somebody in the trump
family would be more sensitive
to people who do not have medical
licenses
diagnosing politicians from afar
plenty of people have diagnosed your
father from afar and i i'm sure it
offends you
your father-in-law from afar i'm sure it
offends you you don't have any standing
to say
noticing him what i'm saying
just uncomfortable as bad of a person as
lara trump is
it actually makes me a little
uncomfortable may i guess i don't have
that
sociopath gene that so many people have
um
to watch her implode so badly doesn't
this campaign have to stop sending her
out because these interviews
this can't be helping can it and the
real hypocrisy of course here is trump
is a mess
as far as this type of thing goes trump
glitches and malfunctions constantly
yosemites he comes off of air force one
and can't find his limo wanders off has
to be brought back by the arm by secret
service
says where is rudy rudy sitting right in
front of him ulysses
s grant he wants to know the oranges of
an investigation he said people want
donald
trump who is she even to be talking
about
cognitive decline when she's supporting
donald trump it just none of it makes
any sense
really really bad uh instance for lara
trump
again i think they've got to stop
sending her out but who am i to
suggest to them they think this helps
them and by all means continue doing it
as many of you know donald trump's
personal lawyer
rudy giuliani has once again re-entered
the spotlight
because of his role in the recent new
york post story
more and more of which is being debunked
daily and one of the speculations about
rudy giuliani for a while it's been
written about for a long time not
something i came up with
is that rudy has a serious drinking
problem and that in particular
there was an effort to keep rudy off of
nighttime television because then it was
more likely that rudy giuliani would be
drunk and that yeah sure
the afternoons could be tough because he
would you know maybe have a few too many
with lunch
but that the night time was really
really the problem now i won't go back
through all of the archives but we've
seen clips
before of rudy giuliani showing up
slurring
one eye half shut one day half his hair
was was like shaved he has like shaved
half of his head
maybe it was just a combing issue
crooked glasses
shiny eyes red eyes that you know the
entire thing
anyway donald trump's other former
lawyer
michael cohen went on msnbc
and straight up said rudy giuliani is
drunk all the time
and it's not speculation it's based on
what i
meaning michael cohen has seen take a
look i mean
rudy is rudy's drunk all the time
which is a big problem and that's what
makes him susceptible because
his faculties are gone he behaves crazy
now
as a journalist and i have to ask you
are you sharing an opinion are you
sharing an observation like you've seen
him a drink x amount that's the same
thing an investigator would have well
i've seen no no
i've seen him drink to the point like
he's a high school drunk
um and it makes him susceptible and he
takes the information that he gets and
he provides it off to the president
and simply because rudy who used to be
considered you know a
i mean a real a real litigator and he
was
considered to be america's mayor is now
really just a joke
the one thing there that we of course
know to be true
is that rudy giuliani is now considered
to be a joke but that's not actually
what's relevant here
and to be really really careful this is
not
haha rudy is an alcoholic this is about
yet another person who has a direct line
to trump
and is directing much of the opposition
stories
trying to help trump he is allegedly
heavily influencing this and we are
learning that his state of mind and
actions
may be affected by drugs that make you
make bad decisions if you go to
counterintelligence 101
one of the things any good operative
knows
is when an individual would be
susceptible
to alcohol or other substances uh to
disinhibit them in ways that could be
advantageous to an adversary if you're
working a target
you would of course know this rudy
admits
that it's a 50 chance he was working
with a russian spy
on the old the eventual new york post
story we know
rudy was a big factor in pushing for the
story to be published despite the
hesitations
that we learned about yesterday thanks
to the new york times
by new york post staffers who were
saying i don't think we should even be
publishing this
this is exactly how people get taken
advantage of by professionals
now the counter to this would be let's
not just say
it's alcohol's fault rudy giuliani is a
wealthy privileged man
with a working brain who is choosing
not only to work for trump but to
continue working for donald trump and
while
the individual action might be affected
maybe by his alcohol consumption if you
believe what michael cohen says
the you know giuliani has
agency here and um he is a
uh willing participant rudy giuliani's
daughter who is supporting joe biden has
written about
rudy is choosing to do this you can't
just say it's the alcohol it can be both
that judy that rudy rather is of course
complicit
but open to being taken extra advantage
of
because of the drinking that many now
have alleged also interesting by the way
from that interview i showed you is from
uh an ari melber
interview on msnbc uh
one of the other things that michael
cohen said
is that chris christie's debate prep for
trump
included suggesting trigger biden
stutter by interrupting a lot it'll make
biden stutter and he will look bad this
has been denied by chris christie
seems totally plausible uh and it is it
is merely an allegation
but as far as the drunkenness thing if
michael cohen were making this up
rudy could sue him and rudy's not going
to sue him and there's every indication
michael cohen is telling the truth
because it's what
anybody who's seen rudy on tv
particularly the nighttime appearances
would suspect more sad than anything
is i mean listen alcoholism is a health
issue
what's particularly sad is that
individuals
who may be um in vulnerable states
because of their substance abuse are
being deputized
to drive main narratives primary
narratives
um in the trump smear campaign against
joe biden and that's uh
that's pretty ugly stuff we have a
voicemail number that number is
219 to david p uh here is a voicemail
from a us
marine who wants to know why do
republicans use us as
props very interesting take a listen
david uh this is uh matt big fan of a
show
so the question i wanted to ask you is
when it comes to uh support and kind of
uh
bowing your chest about being patriotic
a lot of politicians
will use the military as props
um i might i'm a marine myself
and uh and i and i see uh people talking
about how trump just loves the military
because he'll do this these very
superficial things
like uh like hug the american flag and
talk about how brave the troops are and
stuff like that
and my question is do you what do you
think it is about uh
the military polling uh so well with
republicans when
they uh they so they so very obviously
use it uh
use us as a prop and the democrats
aren't
aren't uh innocent of it but it feels
like the republicans do it
a lot more uh thanks david excellent
voicemail
so first of all let's take this piece by
piece
the things trump does for the military
are sort of like
i got a voicemail a couple weeks ago
from some trump is saying
david you're jewish why don't you love
what trump has done trump is great for
the jews he loves
israel and he moved the embassy and blah
blah blah
and i had to explain american jews are
very liberal
and nothing that trump has done helps
get a peace deal done which for me
as an american jew and it's a foreign
policy uh uh
issue i want to see a peace deal and
moving the
embassy from tel aviv to jerusalem does
nothing it's just
it's it's optics and posturing and it's
the exact same thing
with the military so then you get to the
interesting question which is why does
the why do republicans and trump pull so
well among the military so there's a
couple different things going on there
at the base level more republicans are
joining the military
okay so it's not that the military
makes people republicans although i'm
sure that that happens to some degree
it's that you have an organization that
attracts more republicans which is why
you see the military tend to support
more republicans than democrats in the
presidential race however
this year the republican numbers among
the military
are the worst they've been i don't know
how long but for a very long time
check out the recent uh military times
poll so important to understand a bunch
of different things but what's important
is that you
are identifying that the things donald
trump does
are meaningless they are not really
supporting the troops much like george w
bush sending troops into an optional war
for fake reasons
was not supportive of the troops
supportive would be let's not send them
into harm's way
and i'm glad you're recognizing that i
hope more of your
your military colleagues will we have a
great bonus show for you today i had the
opportunity
last night to take advantage of some of
the prepping i had done
i had a situation come up yesterday
where i was prepared
thanks to my prepping it didn't go so
well i will tell you why
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video